i'm curious to ask people are trying to
figure out venom's potential
relationship with spider-man down the
road do you think that this incarnation
of venom could ever be a spider-man
villain or would he have to be retooled
like to sort of fit into sort of that
spider-man world or could he fit into a
sinister six
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
now the sony spider-man universe which
coincidentally could actually end up
being kind of the same universe and i'm
definitely going to talk about that in
this video but the big thing happening
right now is sony is actually teasing
something way bigger than just venom let
there be carnage in fact it actually
does tease that venom and spider-man are
going to be going up against each other
very very soon and we have some reports
today that talk about when exactly we'll
see spider-man go up against venom and
as i talked about in previous videos and
as i teased in the beginning of the
video director andy serkis of venom and
venom 2 has pretty much confirmed that
spider-man and venom are about to meet
so if you want to stay up to date on
venom and spider-man be sure to
subscribe hit that notification bell so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
videos so let's go ahead and start off
with these new promotions that sony is
doing for venom let there be carnage
because they are quite different so the
first promo that we noticed was a little
bit different happened a few days ago
and it comes from the sony pictures
official twitter account and here's what
they posted in two weeks the universe is
expanding in venom let there be carnage
exclusively in movie theaters on october
1st now this is interesting and caught a
lot of people's eyes because if this was
a normal venom let there be carnage
movie the universe wouldn't really be
extending now obviously the reason that
we think the universe is expanding is
because of all of the rumors that have
been going around about spider-man and
venom finally meeting up and the timing
of this tweet which i will go on to talk
about in depth in a bit is lining up
with tom hardy and andy circus the
director of venom and venom 2 both
talking about how spider-man and venom
will meet so this tweet was a little bit
curious but then they sent out another
tweet not too long after a couple of
days after and this one got even more
intriguing the tweet said there's
something way bigger happening discover
it in venom let there be carnage
exclusively in movie theaters october
1st get tickets now they literally said
there's something way bigger happening
but in this post they also posted more
footage of venom let there be carnage
and the way that they did this is rather
interesting as well just take a look at
this brief
clip we've been waiting in the darkness
for you
on october 1st
the universe
is expanding it's something way bigger
than you and me
i'm done with this guy
why me
we all have secrets you know what
secrets wanted they went out
venom exclusively in movie theaters
october 1st ricky 13th so as we can see
here it says the universe is expanding
and then it shows tom hardy saying
there's something way bigger happening
than you and me and then immediately
after that it shows woody harrelson's
cletus cassidy smashing a spider now if
you ask me this is done super
intentionally to me as somebody who
looks for this stuff i see that as a big
nod to spider-man and we can actually
take a look a little bit closer here as
they say the universe is expanding when
they say the universe in this tv spot
clip they actually show detective
mulligan reading from the daily bugle
now of course we all know the daily
bugle from spider-man and this honestly
is actually feeling a lot like sam
raimi's spider-man 3 right now where
eddie brock works for the daily bugle
alongside of spider-man well peter
parker to their knowledge but that's
kind of the feeling that i get right now
and if you take a look at that newspaper
it is the same exact daily bugle from
the sam raimi spider-verse like
literally exactly the same the placement
of the logo between daley and bugle is
exactly the same the font for daily
bugle is the same the slant is the same
like literally this is the same daily
bugle which brings up a lot of questions
especially if you consider the fact that
sony is now advertising their universe
is expanding and the fact that there is
something way bigger happening than we
actually know what exactly is sony
trying to tell us here because venom let
there be carnage isn't exactly a big
multiverse film yet we have the daily
bugle that exists in another universe
appearing in this film we have andy
serkis the director talking about how
eventually spider-man is going to meet
venom i'm curious to ask people are
trying to figure out venom's potential
relationship with spider-man down the
road do you think that this incarnation
of venom could ever be a spider-man
villain or would he have to be retooled
like to sort of fit into sort of that
spider-man world or could he fit into a
sinister six
well i mean there all those questions
are you know ones which we've we've not
purposefully not focused on right now i
mean i i
and and i kind of don't want to um give
any sort of fake hope or false
information about things that might be
happening in the future i mean obviously
at some point he's you know those worlds
are going to collide big time they are i
mean if we get if we are so lucky is to
make more venom movies
and tom hardy and andy circus did an
interview together with brandon davis of
comicbook.com where he asked them about
that infamous picture that tom hardy
posted to his instagram and deleted the
one of venom eating spider-man where you
can see his arms and legs hanging out of
venom's mouth he also asked about the
daily bugle and essentially said is
spider-man on your minds for the future
in which tom hardy replied of course
it's on our minds all the time look at
the photo those little spidey legs
hanging out of the mouth it's very
specific he then said this i think you
can't do a venom story without knowing
spider-man's in the mix he's somewhere
he then went on to say that there are
some events that need to happen before
spider-man and venom meet but spider-man
is always on their minds and in another
interview with jake's takes andy circus
essentially said the same thing
eventually spider-man and venom will
meet some things just have to happen
before then so we have sony posting
these things about the universe
expanding we have the director and tom
hardy talking about how eventually
spider-man is going to go up against
venom and of course we have talks about
the venom let there be carnage post
credit scene now most of you have
probably heard about the venom let there
be carnage post credit scene at this
point and even though it is just a rumor
it does appear to be pretty legitimate
there's leaked audio of it out there
right now that does seem pretty legit
but you never know but sony did do a fan
showing to some lucky fans out there and
some of them after they saw the movie
went to the internet and posted what
they saw in the post credits now i stick
to this being a rumor because they could
simply be trolling we've seen this
happen already with spider-man no way
home people create fake things fake
photos fake trailers all of the time and
pass them off as leaked however this
does seem to be a little bit more
legitimate and considering the fact that
sony is now saying venom's universe is
expanding it would make sense that we
would see spider-man in the post-credits
of venom let there be carnage now i know
a few people have been asking which
spider-man because a lot of people would
like to have andrew garfield's
spider-man return not to mention the
daily bugle is a sam raimi daily bugle
reference so is it toby mcguire that
could be coming back well based off of
what we've heard about the rumor for the
post credits scene and spoilers coming
up if you don't want to hear any about
the rumor it looks like it's going to be
tom holland spider-man according to the
rumors if they do come true it's going
to be very clear that it is in fact tom
hall and spider-man which is pretty much
what i expected yes andrew garfield and
tobin buguire will most likely be in
spiderman no way home but we can't
really expect them to just get up out of
nowhere after years of not playing their
spider-man and just start playing their
characters over again showing up in one
movie for a historic moment having three
spider-man together is one thing that's
different than committing to and taking
up that mantle again for a few years and
like i said the timing for this is kind
of hilarious it looks like sony is kind
of trying to embrace a little bit of
spider-man no way home right now we have
the leaked video of andrew garfield that
came out that andrew garfield himself
would go on to talk about on jimmy
fallon and keep in mind like i said in a
previous video they know what they're
gonna talk about before they go on the
show it's not really like they would
have you think it is their publicists
pretty much get together and tell them
every question that they're gonna ask
before they ask it before they film so
they know exactly what they're doing and
they got permission from sony to talk
about this now they're not admitting
that andrew is in the film but they are
kind of hyping it up and raising the
intrigue of the question is he going to
be in the film this is way different
than before and now we have sony posting
things like the universe is expanding
and things are way bigger than they seem
then we have the rumors of the
post-credits scene of venom let there be
carnage that got out and they probably
weren't planning on that either or maybe
they were but this all seems a little
bit too coincidental as it's all
happening and coming out at the same
time and then you have people like andy
serkis and tom hardy venom himself and
the director talking about how
spider-man is always on their minds
saying yes they will eventually meet now
both of them said that events have to
take place beforehand but i think venom
let there be carnage is most likely that
event they're obviously not going to say
hey yeah and venom 3 spider-man and
venom are going to meet however we have
a recent report from daniel richmond
stating that that is the case according
to a report from his patreon spider-man
will be in venom three according to him
it's happening and considering the fact
that the multiverse looks like it's
actually going to affect the venomverse
in some way shape or form whether that's
the two universes colliding or maybe
they've been in the same universe the
whole entire time who knows but it looks
like they are going to be going up
against each other and considering the
post-credits scene rumor considering the
marketing that sony is doing right now
and considering what tom hardy and andy
serkis have recently said i'm gonna say
that it's gonna happen of course it's
rumor right now but let me know what you
think about this in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
for live updates you can always follow
me on instagram and twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof